bacteria get around they move in
sometimes mysterious ways one of the
most mysterious is via the pilis to get
ahead using pill I a pill is's thrown
forward like a grappling hook after
touch down the pillows is retracted back
and the cell is dragged along but how
does the cell make a grappling hook can
pull it back in researchers used
electronic cryo tomography to take many
many pictures of the pillows machinery
then using genetic techniques they took
away some components and they labeled
others mapping the location of each
protein in the structure with this new
understanding of the structure they
proposed a mechanism for how the pilis
gets sent out and brought back when
activated a motor like protein adds
units together into a chain which pushes
out through the membrane when the
extending chain touches a surface the
proteins change their shape sending a
message back to the machinery in
response to this message a different
motor reverses the process retracting
the pilis and pulling the cell along
taking into account the size and forces
at work here
the pilis motor is probably one of the
strongest molecular motors around